what's going on guys
here at screen junkies we are obsessed
with one thing global domination so when
the good folks behind the hit film
Kingsman the Secret Service available
now in digital HD coming June 9th to
blu-ray offered me the chance to go to
London for some real-life secret agent
training I jumped at the chance so pip
pip cheerio it's across the pond to
London I go
I am super excited to be here in rainy
London England where we're going to find
out what it takes to be a British secret
agent
Kingsman style let's get on with it then
stiff upper lip keep calm and carry on
Oh BAE before my Kingsman training I
decided to hit the rainy streets of
London to see what a worldwide
phenomenon screen junkies has become how
big of a screen junkies fan are you to
me my screen junkies screen junkies I'm
really seeing it on YouTube to be honest
screen junkies I don't know what is
screen junkies so know who they are what
is that that I never heard of it what's
the screen junkie I don't even know
screen junkies I don't know what that is
okay can you explain Doctor Who to me
which one can you explain Doctor Who to
me to be honest some story I really
don't know about doctor hey wait is that
bad aren't they going to take you out of
the country for a night for saying that
not even all right I like it still
confused by Doctor Who and confronted
with some harsh reality I retired to a
local pub to drown my sorrows in
Guinness but I couldn't get too pissed
the next morning my training would begin
we're here at the Huntsman which is the
shop in the movie called the Kingsmen
it's called the Kingsmen in the film in
real life it's called the Huntsman I'm a
little bit confused but that's normal I
am here with the prop master for the
Kingsmen David chessmen David first of
all impressive job thank you very much
wait God obviously Kingsman Harry's
umbrella um obviously standing umbrella
you see every day in London this one of
us he's got a trigger to it so it could
do slightly different things obviously
don't you know I'm Loco standardpen
obviously beautiful pens a beautiful
voice - yeah but maybe not quite as you
would expect as you can buy David's
cookies go may I try in the kitchen oh
yes it will take you somewhere where do
you go um back to my childhood what
about the shoes
classic shoes Jules cleverly beautiful
shoes does the knife come out on this
pen no we we took those away we had them
because we knew you were coming we took
the points out oh yeah take a break
Magnemite you're like who's there
we've got wound about you now that I was
a weapons expert knew his time to talk
to the real deal star of Kingsman and my
new main bloke Taron Egerton
congratulations a bloody brilliant movie
good night you should be an actor thank
you how very kind of you what did you do
to become like a classic British spy I
kind of well I sort of stood there and
people put me in very nice suits and
gave me a gun to hold is the oldest
answer ah like I'm a stupid American
okay that's don't worry yeah you know
you're you're kind but like what could I
do to become more like to take on that
since the series this is the super suit
it's also close you got a good suit
you'd be there that's all it is you've
instantly
um can I pick it up like the goodwill
what you mean oh like second hand oh
yeah yeah of course I'm waiting to get
it you know I think the whole point of
it is that it's just it's bespoke and
that it's fitted to you so what you get
if you get a goodwill suit or a
secondhand we'd say yeah okay then you
just need to get it you know refitted a
little bit too you'd be fine you'd save
the world in no time does being an
international spy help you with the
ladies no no I wish I could say yeah oh
yeah it's been a very quiet here I was
spreading American culture yet I was no
closer to becoming a Kingsman I had one
last shot to gain some valuable Intel
and I could not afford to mess it up my
name is poppy Charles and I'm the PR
marketing manager here at huntsman we
are one of the oldest houses on Savile
Row we were founded back in 18-49 we
used to dress Ian Fleming as well he was
a creator of James Bond
where does Austin Powers get his fancy
clothes I don't know but not Anson
yeah baby yeah all right um so I I think
for most people visiting the shop when
you've come in it's how you imagine
Savile Row would be is it true that some
of the suits here cost as much as 1
million dollars almost getting close
thank you
the configurations are one of the
important bits that they don't mention
to you when they're fitting you but are
the details that they notice about the
way you stand whether you've got a big
paunch if you've been drinking too much
beer
I'm good I'm like um are your sizes
flexible enough to fit say a fat bastard
of course good good Austin Powers - come
on tell me three nothing he was in both
okay - in three good man yet again I
squandered a great opportunity also I
was pulled aside and politely asked not
to make any more Austin Powers
references if you're a lip reader you
can clearly see me saying no more Austin
Powers I think I've dealt a serious blow
English British relations before I got
deported baby it was time for me to
hightail it out of the UK but on my way
out something magical happened I found a
screen junkies fan you know screen
junkies yes oh wow
you know my name no I had a bloody good
time and I want to thank everyone with
Kingsman the Secret Service for allowing
me to go make a fool of myself in a
whole other country and if you haven't
seen Kingsman it's a really fun movie
check it out right now on digital HD and
coming June 9th to blu-ray now in the
spirit of Kingsman who would you say is
the best secret agent of all time let us
know in the comments section below tell
us why and the best answer we're gonna
send you a screen junkies t-shirt I want
to thank you for watching I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye bye